let's just uh return to the breaking
news we brought you uh just a short time
ago that is that the queen has postponed
her privy council meeting this evening
after being advised by doctors to rest
our royal correspondent rhiannon mills
joins us now on the phone uh good
evening rhiannon what else is the palace
saying about this
so it has to be said it is unusual when
it comes to the queen's house for the
queen for the palace to
unnecessarily tell us things that they
don't feel that they have to but i think
because we had anticipated that this
privy council meeting was going to take
place today albeit virtually they've
decided that because it therefore
wouldn't appear in the court circular
tomorrow they have had to tell us that
the doctors up at balmoral have told the
queen to rest now of course that comes
after we saw the queen yesterday for the
first time in a number of weeks as she
very clearly told her advisors told
number 10 that she still wanted to carry
out that important transition of power
between one prime minister and the next
and albeit she couldn't travel herself
down to london but all of the necessary
arrangements were made so that her 14th
prime minister boris johnson could
travel up to scotland to hand in his
resignation and then her 15th prime
minister liz trust could then be
appointed
at valmol of course for the first time
that that has happened uh outside of
london now just to read to you the
statement that we've had from the palace
in full it says that after a full day
yesterday her majesty has this afternoon
accepted doctor's advice to rest this
means that the privy council meeting
that had been due to take place this
evening will be rearranged now as we can
anticipate we've been in this situation
before when there have been concerns
about the queen's health the palace are
not going to necessarily give us any
more detail however i do understand that
the queen is still at balmoral where we
know that she's been enjoying her summer
break
and there's no hospitals involved she
hasn't been transferred anywhere so she
is still
very much at balmoral castle where we
know that she was very comfortable she
enjoys spending time there and we know
that certainly over the last few weeks
she has had her family around her in
terms of this privy council meeting
what's it all about did it have to
happen today well in the past it has
been delayed after a prime minister has
been appointed in essence what normally
happens at that privy council meeting is
that liz trust would take her formal
oath as first lord of the treasury and
also
new members of the cabinet would also be
given their seals of office there would
be as they described kissing of hands
that obviously wouldn't have happened
because it was always going to happen
virtually but we're told in terms of the
mechanisms of government then the fact
that this private council meeting isn't
happening this evening that's not going
to cause any problems but i think yeah
it is telling that the palace have felt
that they have had to tell us once again
that the queen has been advised to rest
by her doctors and i think in essence
that's because otherwise alarm bells may
have started ringing people would have
started asking questions if that privy
council meeting had not appeared in the
court circular
yeah and rihanna we are getting
increasingly um these announcements of
meetings postponed or postponed or
events cancelled but i guess that is
to be expected the queen is after all a
woman of 96 years old
do you know what mark i think certainly
over the last 12 months there has been
what i would say a change
in terms of what the queen has been able
to to carry out i was thinking back to
12 months ago where i was told very
clearly 12 months ago the queen was
looking forward to the autumn uh it was
the end of september she was planting a
tree with the prince of wales she then
opened the scottish parliament she
opened the welsh parliament she carried
out a big business summit at windsor
castle and then it was october last year
you might remember that she was advised
to cancel a trip to northern ireland and
it was only subsequently after that that
we found out that she was she'd been
taken to hospital to have some tests we
were told that we shouldn't be overly
concerned about that but of course it's
going to set some alarm bells ringing
and i think there has some people would
say been what appears to be
some would say a deterioration in her
health certainly in her mobility and her
ability to get around and also i think
what we've been seeing and this
certainly was the case yesterday is that
there is definitely now more of this
common sense approach within the palace
within the family that actually we now
all need to just get used to the fact
that there are some things that she is
just not going to be able to do and for
me why that is interesting is because
certainly over the last five years five
years ago it was it was difficult to
talk about transition it was difficult
to talk about a change or a handing over
now i think we just have to get used to
it and certainly you talk to
constitutional experts for example and
they would have said actually yesterday
she didn't necessarily have to do that
handover of power between the prime
ministers we saw that actually it was
the prince of wales and the duke of
cambridge who stepped in for her as
council of
state when it came to the state opening
of parliament again those mechanisms
could have been put in place but i think
what you have got is you've got a 96
year old monarch who in her mind has no
intention of resigning stepping down as
it were and when she can do those duties
she wants to do them however i think
like anyone who has anyone who's in
their 90s in their family they will
realize that when they do do things like
yesterday and yeah despite the fact that
it was still at balmoral it probably did
as we're now seeing took it out of her
and things do take longer to recover
from and that ultimately is what we're
seeing we saw it at the platinum jubilee
weekend on the thursday we saw her on
the balcony we saw her lighting beacons
friday and saturday she had to rest and
it was up to other members of the family
to step in